Trump's secret documents versus
Hillary's emails block her up no lock
him up lock them up former president
Trump has been fighting to contain and
fundraise from the political thought
after the FBI executed his search
warrant at his residence at Mar-A-Lago
we have since learned that agents sought
to recover classified documents being
stored on site including confidential
documents relating to nuclear weapons or
energy among the items seized by FBI
agents were at least 11 sets of
classified documents for marked top
secret three marked a secret and three
marked as confidential the lowest level
of classified information after the
warrant was unsealed were at least parts
of it we learned that the FBI is
investigating the form present for
potential criminal violations of the
Espionage Act obstruction and
destruction of records were they looking
for the Hillary Clinton emails that were
deleted but they are around someplace in
response several of the ex-president's
defenders in Congress have seamlessly
flipped from back the blue to defund the
FBI other allies have opted to invoke
their favorite defensive all things
Trump but her emails and by her I mean
mean Hillary Clinton whose use of a
private email server while serving as
Secretary of State resulted in multiple
investigations into her handling of
classified information and many of
Trump's Defenders have claimed that he
is a target of a double standard and a
political Witch Hunt compared to Hillary
Clinton Senator Lindsey Graham even went
on to Fox News to suggest that
Prosecuting Trump while not Prosecuting
Clinton would result in massive rioting
if there's a prosecution of Donald Trump
for mishandling classified information
after the Clinton debacle which you
presided over and did a hell of a good
job there'll be riots in the streets now
at least initially this comparison
doesn't seem crazy so let's compare the
investigations into Hillary Clinton's
private email server with the FBI
seizure of Donald Trump's top secret
documents at Mar-A-Lago and address
whether Clinton received preferential
treatment compared to the former
president when it comes to handling of
classified material so what was that
whole Scandal about well in January 2009
Clinton aide set up an email domain
called Clinton email.com on a private
server located at her Chappaqua New York
home while running the state department
Clinton exclusively used email addresses
connected to that private server for
both work and personal emails rather
than using a state.gov email for
government work and a separate private
account for her personal affairs in May
of 2014 the House of Representatives
voted to create a select committee to
investigate the 2012 terrorist attack on
government facilities in Benghazi Libya
that killed four Americans including
Ambassador Chris Stevens and on March
2nd 2015 Clinton's private email server
became a national story when the New
York Times ran a front page article on
the subject the article detailed that
the system quote may have violated
Federal requirements and was
characterized as alarming by current and
former government archive officials
Clinton claimed she set up her own email
for convenience so she would only need
to carry One smartphone with one email
rather than two devices for work and
personal affairs but Skeptics believe
the more likely explanation was that
Clinton who was gearing up to run for
president wanted to be the sole Arbiter
of what emails were personal and what
emails were government business that
needed to be turned over in response to
Freedom of Information requests and
Congressional inquiries and Clinton's
team did decide on their own what emails
needed to be preserved and which did not
igniting a firestorm from critics that
exist to this day and on March 10 2015
Clinton's office disclosed that she kept
30 490 work-related emails and deleted
approximately 31 830 emails that she had
deemed personal which she described as
Communications about private matters
like yoga routines her daughter's
wedding and her mother's funeral however
it turns out those emails had only been
intended to have been deleted and had
not actually been deleted until three
weeks after Congress subpoenaed
Clinton's Benghazi related emails and
back in December 2014 Clinton's former
Chief of Staff Cheryl Mills had told
Platte River networks the company that
was managing the private server that
Clinton quote decided she no longer
needed access to any of her emails older
than 60 days Mills instructed an
unidentified PRN employee to modify the
email retention policy to reflect this
change however the PRN employee
mistakenly did not implement this change
and did not delete the old emails when
requested sometime between March 25th
and 31st 2015 the this employee erased
the emails using a free utility program
called bleach bid Clinton later told the
FBI that she was not aware that the
emails were deleted in late March 2015
and a Clinton campaign spokesman claimed
that the PRN employee was advised to
retain all data in compliance with the
Congressional subpoena but acted on his
own to complete the prior deletion
request in September 2015 investigators
with the FBI were able to recover some
of the deleted emails Clinton's critics
have accused her and her AIDS of
deleting emails that were under
subpoenaed to cover up wrongdoing of
course during the campaign chance of
lock her up were regular features at
Trump rallies well Trump himself
famously invited Russia to hack Hillary
Clinton's server to find the deleted
emails Russia if you're listening I hope
you're able to find the 30 000 emails
that are missing
I think you will probably be rewarded
mightily by our press but in July 2015
inspectors General at the state
department and the Director of National
Intelligence asked the doj to review
whether classified information was
compromised by Clinton's use of private
email the following month it was
confirmed the FBI was investigating
whether Clinton or her staff violated
federal laws governing classified
information and whether foreign powers
or hostile actors had hacked the private
server the FBI investigated Clinton
under three criminal statutes 18 USC's
793 which makes it a felony to mishandle
classified information in an intentional
or grossly negligent way 18 USC 1924
which makes it a misdemeanor to
knowingly remove classified information
from appropriate systems or storage
facilities and 18 USC 2071 which makes
it illegal to willfully and unlawfully
conceal remove or destroy Federal
records and on July 5th 2016 FBI
director James Comey held a press
conference announcing the Department's
conclusion that no reasonable prosecutor
would bring a criminal case against the
former Secretary of State due to lack of
requisite Criminal Intent nevertheless
Comey also so famously remarked that
Clinton and her aides were quote
extremely careless in their handling of
very sensitive highly classified
information and on October 28 2016 11
days before the election day Comey
announced the FBI was reviewing new
emails that could be relevant to the
probe of Clinton's server the emails
were being examined as part of the FBI's
investigation into disgraced former
Congressman Anthony Weiner who was the
estranged husband of top Clinton aide
Huma abedin in a November 6 2016 letter
to lawmakers Comey announced his
agency's review of emails was complete
and it did not alter the previous
conclusion that Clinton should not be
prosecuted two days later Clinton was
defeated by Donald Trump in the
presidential election and while there
are conflicting accounts of the emails
at issue it seems that of the tens of
thousands of emails that were reviewed
113 were found to contain classified
information and only three of those had
classification markers 65 of those
emails were deemed secret and 22 deemed
Top Secret in 2016 Comey said that
Clinton should have known that some of
those 103 teen were classified but noted
that there were others that she might
have understandably missed on June 14
2018 the doj's office of Inspector
General released a report on the FBI and
doj's handling of the Clinton
investigation the report found no
evidence of political bias and
reaffirmed the decision not to prosecute
Clinton and in September 2019 a
three-year State Department
investigation concluded that 38 current
and former State Department officials
were culpable in 91 cases of sending
classified information that ended up in
Clinton's email server though the report
stated that the private email increased
the vulnerability of classified
information investigators found quote no
persuasive evidence of systemic
deliberate mishandling of classified
information but let's compare that to
what we know right now about the Trump
naralago Scandal which admittedly is
absolutely not complete information at
this time but after the FBI executed a
search warrant on Donald Trump's
Mar-A-Lago estate the former president
posted a statement on his social media
platform through social attacking what
what he called the quote weaponization
of the justice system calling the search
political targeting at the highest level
Trump claimed that there was a double
standard with how the FBI handled
Hillary Clinton's email investigation
quote Hillary Clinton was allowed to
delete an acid wash 33 000 emails after
they were subpoenaed by Congress
absolutely nothing has happened to hold
her accountable now putting aside that
Clinton did not literally cover the
server in Bleach obviously you take that
internally to fight covid Trump and his
allies have long suggested that Hillary
Clinton should have been prosecuted or
at least at a minimum Prosecuting Trump
would be unfair of the double standard
created for Clinton but the use of
private emails and other unofficial
Communications for government employees
has come up more often than you'd think
with varying degrees of uproar and
concern and though that certainly
doesn't excuse Clinton's Behavior it's
probably important to look at other
contexts and comparisons among those who
recently used private email accounts to
conduct official government business in
the Trump Administration that includes
advisor Stephen Miller former Chief of
Staff runs priebus former National
Economic Council director Gary Cohn
former deputy National Security adviser
Katie McFarland and former advisor Steve
Bannon Trump's son-in-law Jared Kushner
and daughter Ivanka Trump both
presidential advisors used either
personal email accounts or the messaging
app WhatsApp to conduct official
business and since WhatsApp messages are
encrypted there's no record of the
message unless Jared and Ivanka actually
stored copies of those messages
kushner's lawyer said his client quote
took images of communications from
WhatsApp and forwarded them to official
accounts but when asked if Kushner used
the app to share classified information
his attorney to birds saying quote
that's above my pay grade former White
House trade adviser Peter Navarro also
fighting contempt charges for refusing
to testify to the January 6 committee is
currently embroiled in his own
presidential record dispute with the
national archives in August 2022 the doj
suit Navarro claiming he refused to turn
over emails retained on a private
account while working for the Trump
Administration and even Colin Powell who
served as Secretary of State under
George W bush from 2001 to 2005
acknowledged using a laptop on a private
line for State Department business
including sending notes to ambassadors
and foreign ministers via personal email
and in a January 2009 Email exchange
with Hillary Clinton Powell told
incoming secretary of state that he used
a private phone and computer to do
business with foreign leaders and
communicate with senior Department
officials on their own personal email
accounts while Powell said that Clinton
was not influenced by his email with
respect to setting her up on her own
server he also said he was quote not
aware at the time of any requirement for
private unclassified exchanges to be
treated as official records but again to
emphasize this is all bad it's a problem
in Washington whether it's Hillary
Clinton or anyone else doing it now
before we get to the legal consequences
let's compare and contrast some of the
factual differences because some of them
just jump right out first of all at the
time of this particular Scandal Hillary
Clinton was a government employee in
fact she was Secretary of State just a
few rungs below the president of the
United States she was conducting
government business at the highest
levels she had an active security
clearance and she had Communications
with other people who had security
clearances to view the classified
documents and classified information and
she was conducting government business
on a private server which she absolutely
should not have been doing and
ironically was a violation of the pra
the presidential records act and while
there's no doubt the classified material
got mixed in by all accounts this was an
inadvertent mishandling in contrast
Donald Trump is not currently a
government employee he doesn't have any
security clearances at all he was not
communicating with people with security
clearances in fact we don't know who had
access to these documents odds are none
of these people had the kinds of
clearances required and we don't know to
whom these documents were transmitted or
had access to them and while it's
possible that Trump's possession of
these government documents started out
as inadvertent it appears clear that at
some point down the chain it was
intentional and conscious to withhold
these documents from being returned to
the government there's also a volume and
number difference in Trump's case we're
talking about hundreds of classified
documents potentially thousands or tens
of thousands of pages of classified
material we can tell from the
photographs that many if not all of
these documents are clearly marked as
classified or top secret versus a
comparatively small amount in the case
of Hillary Clinton you have 113 emails
that contain classified information only
three of which were marked as
confidential and while it wouldn't
change the underlying culpability there
was a big difference in how the
situation was handled once discovered
Hillary Clinton cooperated with the
doj's investigation it doesn't appear
that Hillary Clinton ever represented
that everything had been turned over
when it clearly hadn't in comparison
Donald Trump it seems consciously hid
the documents refused to turn it over
and lied to investigators but just
because the situation is different
doesn't mean that Hillary Clinton should
not have been prosecuted so let's talk
about the charge that she received
preferential treatment on July 5th 2016
FBI director James Comey held a press
conference where he made the following
statement although we did not find clear
evidence that secretary Clinton or her
colleagues intended to violate laws
governing the handling of classified
information there is evidence that they
were extremely careless in their
handling of very sensitive highly
classified information so was comey's
statement that no reasonable prosecutor
would bring a case correct or evidence
of political bias well in 2016 the FBI
told the Senate Judiciary Committee that
quote extremely careless was comey's
Common Sense way of describing the
actions of Clinton and her colleagues
and was not intended to describe the
legal standard for gross negligence
under the Espionage Act but Trump and
his supporters have argued if Clinton
was indeed extremely careless with the
classified materials the failure to
prosecute her at least for grossly
mishandling classified material under
the Espionage Act was a miscarriage of
justice but it's not enough to look at
the statute we have to look at how
prosecutors have brought charges under
the section now back in 2016 Andrew
Torres the lawyer and host of the
podcast opening arguments which is
excellent researched all prosecutions
under the Espionage Act and out of 240
cases Torres only found nine cases that
had been brought under the gross
negligence part of the statute and in
all of those gross negligence cases the
defendant was found to have made quote a
deliberate decision to hide or destroy
information that the defendant knew to
be confidential and improperly in his
possession Torres concluded that comey's
statement that no reasonable prosecutor
would bring a case against Clinton was
correct writing quote I can find no case
anywhere in which any person has ever
been sentenced under the Espionage Act
without evidence that said person
unambiguously knew the material that
they were removing was confidential
since that fact is not present here I
conclude that Hillary Clinton received
no special treatment when the government
declined to indict her we're talking
about 18 USC 793 that's the Espionage
Act it is the same law with some
amendments that was used to prosecute
Julius and Ethel Rosenberg virtually all
of the prosecutions under it are for
what we typically think of as spy stuff
right someone with access to documents
that relate to the National Defense
steals or makes a copy of those
documents and prosecutors don't even
have to prove that person ever sold it
to a hostile foreign power or another
spy you just have to prove that they
took the document you can infer that
they weren't going to do anything good
with it and while Espionage no longer
carries the death penalty it is a felony
with a 10-year maximum sentence and
that's why we never find any cases that
are even a close analog to secretary
Clinton's conduct it isn't Espionage
when someone leaves a file cabinet or a
door unlocked or leaves a top secret
document out on their desk that's
certainly extremely careless but those
cases aren't considered Espionage you
probably noticed I use the weasel word
virtually virtually all the prosecutions
under the espion actor for spy stuff but
what about the ones the handful that
aren't consider USV Gonzalez this
involved an air force staff sergeant who
was stationed in Anchorage Alaska and
was taken off to go party with his buddy
who worked for an oil company Sarge
grabbed a bunch of his stuff to give to
his buddy and while doing so
accidentally grabbed two classified
documents when he got to prudo Bay he
discovered his mistake but instead of
calling his Superior and owning up to it
he told his buddy hey man I'm just going
to stick these two documents in your
desk and totally make sure you remind me
before I leave to take them back with me
to the Air Force Base okay for whatever
reason use your imagination the sarge
and his buddy like totally spaced on the
documents and just left them there in
the desk that might not have been such a
big deal except that the Buddy didn't
actually have his own desk he shared it
with another guy named Nick and Nick got
to work Monday morning opened up his
desk drawer saw the bright red
confidential sticker on the cover sheet
of the two documents and freaked out you
know as you do he called his boss his
boss called the Air Force and you one
thing led to another Sarge was sentenced
to 43 days of confinement a little less
than the 10 years discharged for bad
conduct reduced in rank or consider USB
Gaffney which coincidentally involved
another air force staff sergeant
although this guy would never ever Trek
off to Northern Alaska for a
weekend-long bender now this guy was a
good family man he just wanted to spend
more time at home with his pregnant wife
and so he did but one of Sarge's chop
duties was to shred classified documents
and being that this was 1982 shredders
were super slow rather than spending
hours shredding documents like a
dumbbell he did what you know anybody
with a pregnant wife might do grabbed
all the documents and then deposited
them in a nearby dumpster problem solved
but except that helicopter parenting
wouldn't be invented for two decades so
kids played in dumpsters all the time
some Rugrat found the documents took
them home Daddy found them under the bed
okay could have been worse and called
the Air Force all of these cases that
don't quite fit into the spy stuff
category are like this they're cases in
which the defendant absolutely knew that
they had compromised documents in their
possession and then they still did the
stupid thing and then they tried to
actively cover their tracks as Jim Comey
put it all of the cases prosecuted
involved some combination of clearly
intentional and willful mishandling of
classified information the very behavior
for which secretary Clinton was
exonerated but look don't take legal
advice from a podcast take legal advice
from a YouTube channel but why would
prosecutors only bring cases involving
deliberate conduct when the statute
requires only gross negligence well
that's because the gross negligence
statute might be unconstitutionally
vague under the vagueness doctrine
statutes that are vague indefinite or in
certain violate due process because such
laws fail to give the individual proper
notice of how to conform their conduct
to follow the law and in a case called
Goran versus the United States the
Supreme Court suggested that the then
operative provisions of the Espionage
Act was not unconstitutionally vague
only because it criminalized intentional
conduct quote the obvious delimiting
words in the statute are those requiring
intent or reason to believe that the
information to be obtained is to be used
to the injury of the United States which
requires those prosecuted to have acted
in bad faith and in an August 16 2016
letter explaining the decision not to
bring the charges the FBI told the
Senate Judiciary Committee that the doj
had only prosecuted for intentional
mishandling of documents because the
gross negligence language is likely
unconstitutional they said quote there
are concerns about the Constitutional
implications of criminalizing grossly
negligent conduct without requiring the
government to prove that the person knew
he or she was doing something wrong the
letter noted that only one person in 99
years had been charged with mishandling
classified documents in a grossly
negligent way a charge that was
dismissed when the defendant pleaded
guilty to making false statements so
given the potential unconstitutionality
of gross negligence prosecutions the doj
has opted to almost exclusively
prosecute cases involving only
intentional misconduct but is Trump
subject to an unfair double standard by
law enforcement well so far legal
experts are pretty much unanimous that
Trump's case is much much worse and it's
not subject to a double standard as more
information about the FBI search has
been released legal experts have weighed
in on whether Trump has been treated
unfairly when compared to Clinton David
lofman who headed the Justice
Department's counterintelligence section
until 2018
said there's simply no comparison
between Clinton's emails and the judge
approved search of Mar-A-Lago quote
people sling these cases around to suit
their political agenda but every case
has to stand on its own circumstances
for the Department to pursue a search
warrant in Mar-A-Lago tells me that the
quantum and quality of the evidence they
were reciting in a search warrant and
affidavit that an FBI agent swore to was
likely so pulverizing in its Force as to
eviscerate any notion that the search
warrant and this investigation is
politically motivated and laughman has
experience in this area not only did he
personally oversee the investigation
into Hillary Clinton's emails he also
managed the investigation into David
Petraeus and here's a quick summary of
what led to the FBI getting a search
warrant to recover classified documents
and presidential records from Trump's
Residence at Mar-A-Lago when Trump left
office in January 2021 boxes of records
that his White House counsel said should
have gone to the National Archives were
instead shipped to Trump's Residence at
Mar-A-Lago officials at the National
Archives spent eight months in
negotiations with Trump to return the
documents 15 documents were returned in
January 2022 upon reviewing the
documents though Nara saw documents
clearly marked classified intermingled
with non-classified info resulting in a
referral to the doj to investigate
possible mishandling of classified
material the FBI had evidence that
dozens of additional boxes with
classified info were still being kept at
Mar-A-Lago so the doj obtained a grand
jury subpoena seeking documents bearing
classification markings that were still
in Trump's possession on June 3rd
Trump's custodian of Records turned over
additional boxes to the doj then signed
a certification swearing that a diligent
search had been done in all responsive
documents produced Trump's lawyer told
the FBI agents that all boxes of
classified records had been kept in a
secure storage room however the FBI
uncovered multiple sources of evidence
that the response to the grand jury
subpoena was incomplete and the
classified documents were still on site
the FBI also had evidence that quote
government records were likely concealed
and removed from the storage room and
that efforts were likely taken to
obstruct the government's investigation
so it's against this backdrop over a
year of delay plays in returning all
classified documents voluntarily not
turning over documents in response to
the subpoena and evidence of obstruction
of justice that the government finally
got a search warrant for Mar-A-Lago and
conducted the search of course we got
more information on August 18 2022 when
judge Bruce Reinhardt the magistrate
overseeing the Mar-A-Lago search
unsealed the warrant cover sheet
revealing the FBI was investigating
potential violations of 18 USC 793
willful retention of National Defense
information 18 USC 2071 concealment or
removal of government records and 18 USC
1519 obstruction of a federal
investigation Clinton was also
investigated for violating section 2071
but Bradley Moss a well-respected lawyer
who handles National Security cases said
that the cases of Clinton and Trump are
significantly different given Trump's
willful retention of classified
documents quote Trump took properly
marked hard copy classified documents
from the White House shipped them to
Florida and stored them in an unsecured
location at his residence Moss also
noted that while some Trump document
were clearly marked as classified the
presence of classified information in
Clinton's emails was less obvious quote
the emails were never marked as
classified because there were
Communications from unclassified
government accounts and similarly the
FBI's August 2016 letter justifying its
decision not to charge Clinton the
bureau noted how past prosecutions
involved some combination of clearly
intentional and willful mishandling of
classified info significant quantities
of classified info exposed to support
and inference of intent or indications
of disloyalty to the United States none
of which were present with Clinton as
examples the FBI cited past prosecutions
of xcia director David Petraeus who
knowingly exposed significant classified
materials to his biographer turned
mistress and then lied about it when
confronted former Bill Clinton National
Security adviser Sandy Berger who stole
clearly marked classified documents from
the National Archives by hiding them in
his clothes and Afghanistan Naval
reservist Brian nishamura Who removed
hundreds of clearly classified documents
from classified U.S military Information
Systems lied to investig Gators about
them and then destroyed large quantities
of classified documents contrasting
these cases with the Clinton case the
FBI highlighted Clinton received three
emails containing C markings for
confidential and that wasn't clear
evidence of knowledge or Criminal Intent
as further evidence of lack of Criminal
Intent the FBI highlighted that Clinton
did not originate this information but
rather the email chains were forwarded
by staff members with the confidential
markings buried deep in the email
threads the doj's 2018 report on
Clinton's emails also concluded that the
classification markings were not clear
in addition over 2 000 emails were
retroactively characterized as including
classified information which underscores
the uncertainty regarding the status of
Clinton's emails in Trump's case the
ex-president was explicitly notified not
only that he was illegally in possession
of Highly classified documents but the
doj and intelligence Community had
concerns at those classified items were
not safely stored according to the Wall
Street Journal an individual familiar
with the boxes from Nara had alerted
investigators the documents were not not
being stored securely which heightened
the agency's urgency to seize the
documents in the May 10 2022 letter Nara
informed Trump's attorneys that the
boxes recovered from Mar-A-Lago in
January contained more than 700 pages of
classified material including documents
marked extremely sensitive and after
reports from inside Mar-A-Lago that
individuals were seen moving boxes in
and out of the room in June of 2022 the
doj subpoenaed the Trump Organization
for mar-a-lago's security footage of the
area since the search the government has
recovered more than 300 documents with
classified markings and according to the
partially unsealed affidavit that gave
rise to the search warrant Nara referred
the matter to the doj for investigation
following a preliminary review of 15
boxes of documents Nara warned the doj
that classified documents were
haphazardly mixed with quote newspapers
magazines and printed news articles
among other items of most significant
concern to Nara the classified records
were unfolded intermixed with other
records and otherwise improperly
identified these fears were confirmed
when agents who searched Mar-A-Lago
quote found highly sensitive and
classified documents lying in unsecured
places outside the storage room at the
Justice Department officials had earlier
asked to be better secured when the FBI
conducted a preliminary review of 15
boxes that Trump finally turned over to
Nara in May of 2022 the agency
discovered that Trump was in possession
of at least quote 184 unique documents
with classified markings including 67
documents marked as confidential 92
documents marked a secret and 25
documents marked as top secret if you're
the president of the United States you
could declassify just by saying it's
Declassified even by thinking about it
the affidavit further alleges that the
return boxes include classified
documents related to quote clandestine
human sources who help U.S intelligence
gathering as well as how it conducts
foreign surveillance and information
under lawful domestic surveillance these
are some of America's most closely held
secrets and disclosure of this
information could lead to sources being
compromised or killed and the
intermingling of personal papers with
these highly classified documents as
well as their location in what is
reported to be the for former
president's personal desk all go to
state of mind and that former president
Trump may have intentionally kept these
documents and been actively reviewing
them long after they were requested by
the government presidents leave they
take things they take documents they
take things they read them Clinton was
comparatively more Cooperative with the
doj's investigation of her server than
Trump has been with his classified
documents which forced the doj to be
more aggressive with Trump Clinton
critics would likely dispute such a
characterization though noting that 30
000 emails were deleted weeks after
Clinton received a congressional
subpoena though the deletion was
apparently by an unidentified server
employee Clinton Defenders would counter
that she did voluntarily turn over her
private email server to the doj in
August of 2015 and the following month
the FBI was able to recover many of the
deleted emails Clinton also voluntarily
met with the FBI for a three and a half
hour interview on July 3 2016. in
contrast Trump was vehemently opposed to
turning over the documents voluntarily
even in response to a government
subpoena which is why a search warrant
was apparently required to get the
documents back the redacted affidavit
alleges that Nara began making requests
for the document's return in May of 2021
and it took eight months of delay before
team Trump informed Nara that there were
boxes to be recovered on August 16 2022
the New York Times detailed additional
efforts by the FBI to recover nara's
documents and the article highlights how
Trump blew off demands to have the
document's return telling several
advisors quote it's not theirs it's mine
now if you'd like to hear more about the
legal Misfortune about people in the
Trump orbit you can watch an entire
exclusive video we did about Steve
bannon's upcoming fraud trial that's the
one where he got pardoned but then New
York State went after him anyway and
it's a question of whether double
jeopardy applies but I'm sorry to tell
you that that exclusive video is really
exclusive and you can't watch it on
YouTube but you can see it with today's
sponsor curiosity stream and nebula
because on nebula my videos always come
out early with zero ads and I release
exclusive content all the time like that
exclusive Steve Bannon video or an
entire video about the legal stories
that are not safe for work and are too
hot for YouTube as well as things
misunderstand about the Constitution why
nfts are bad for creators and my first
full-length documentary bad law works
good and even though this exclusive
content is exclusive to nebula you can
get access to it for free with
curiositystream and it's not just me
nebula is Creator owned and Creator
operated there's exclusive content
released every single day multiple times
every single day and by the way we've
been developing nebula like crazy now
has apps for iOS Android Apple TV Roku
Fire TV and Android TV and was recently
nominated for its first streamy and
we're thrilled that nebula is partnering
with curiosity stream because they're
the go-to source for the best
documentaries and long-form educational
content on the internet they even have
an entire section devoted to Unsolved
Mysteries and crime so if you like my
videos you'll love the thousands of
titles on curiosity stream now the best
way to get access to nebula and all of
the incredible content is through the
amazing curiosity stream nebula bundle
deal with his current sales price of
less than 15 dollars per year to get
access to both sites and to be clear
that nebulous subscription is not a
trial it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member there just isn't
a better deal in stream where you get
access to two great streaming sites with
content that you'll actually watch and
enjoy all for less than fifteen dollars
per year at the current sales price and
what's more signing up will actually
help countless independent educational
creators Beyond just legal eagle so sign
up right now by clicking on the button
that's on screen right now or down below
in the description it's a great way to
support educational content and tons of
exclusive content that you'll love so
click on the link that's on screen right
now and after that click on this box
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court